you know what time it is burger show
burger show the burger show burger show
baby
it's awesome i love the show i'm a big
fan season eight we made it fast oh look
at that look at that cheese stretch that
looks insane look at this oh my god oh
saucy we've got your classics the
simplest the better that's a really
really tasty burger oh that's naughty
it's gonna get that lace it's the stuff
of dreams we've got your bells and
whistles i picked a
that's wild oh my god what is this i'm
trying to expand our burger horizons
here we're gonna go there we're gonna go
weird
wait is this a burger taco plot twist oh
gosh there's lighting
and we have a hell of a lineup of guests
just for you alvin that's a beautiful
burger
it's burger time
a burger is a piece of art to me if
there was one burger to rule them all
the burger shows season eight
season
the burger show season eight let's go
[Music]
what's up y'all it's your boy alvin
kylon of the burger show make sure you
like
subscribe and hit that notification bell
if not for me
for the burgers